ancient legends of ultimate chaos at
whose center sprawls the blind idiot God
as a Thoth lord of all things encircled
by his flopping horde of - amorphous
dancers and lulled by the thin
monotonous piping of a demonic flute in
nameless paws the nuclear chaos the
demon Sultan the deep dark the blind
idiot God Lacrosse first mention of
Azeroth was in a note to himself that he
wrote in 1919 the note simply reads as a
thought hideous name the name would then
appear again this time in a note that
Lovecraft wrote referring to a story a
terrible pilgrimage to seek the knighted
throne of the far demon Sultan as a
Thoth like many of the deities that
appear in the Cthulhu Mythos they have a
number of appearances that are fairly
difficult to define the none are as
difficult as that of azor Thoth it is
everything in anything that someone
could envision and everyone envisions
its image differently the image is
forever changing and forever evolving it
is a crate of the universe and all
things inside the omnipotent God the
Creator and supreme ruler of the outer
God's and the great old ones it is
immortal and invincible and cannot be
destroyed because the concept of
destruction only exists in streams we
cannot then truly understand how
powerful as I thought really is because
concepts of speed and strength and other
ways we use to measure power once again
only exists in Azeroth of streams there
is a belief that it uses the form of its
son Niall Arthur tip has an avatar but
that is something we'll cover in a
separate video in the entirety of the
Cthulhu Mythos there is no doubt that as
a Thoth is the most powerful of all of
the deities it should then come as no
surprise that it went on to feature in
several of Lovecraft stories with the
most notable being the dream quest of
unknown Kadath it is often described as
the center of the universe the unknowing
creator of our reality we are nothing
more than a figment of as athos
imagination when it does eventually
awaken from its slumber our reality will
cease to exist
our planet and everything we've come to
know fade into nothing and the only
thing left will be the blind idiot God
when we talk about cosmic horror I think
as our thought is a great example of
what it truly means the existence of an
elliptic being that we cannot truly
understand a being that our existence
solely depends on the idea that the
reality that we think we have created
can be taken from us at
time and we're helpless to do anything
about it this entire notion has inspired
a host of writers and I think one of the
best examples of this is in Lord
Antony's the gods of pagana where he
created the state he named to money huge
Suchet which is almost Stephanie
inspired by a zetha and dance in his
interpretation money you'll sue she
sleeps eternally he's soothing kept in
his slumber by lesser deity who beats a
drum forever
for if he cease for an instant than
money you'd sue Shia will start to awake
and there will be no worlds no gods no
more listen itself is a very clear
reference to the work of Lovecraft as
there are interpretations of as a Thoth
where is described as a mess of nuclear
chaos that can be found outside of the
universe here at his constantly attended
to by a group of alien servants who
shower it with sounds of pipes and drums
ensuring and as a thought remains in its
slumber completely unaware and blind to
the fact of the universe that we and
many other beings call home is nothing
more than a figment of its imagination
what I personally find most interesting
about as a Thoth is that it is
essentially this enormous mindless being
there's unaware of everything and yet it
is so powerful that it can shape and
form realities just by dreaming it does
make you wonder what if as a thought
wasn't - what exactly would it be
capable of if it was conscious as of all
of the Cthulhu Mythos there are so many
interpretations of as a Thoth that you
can literally believe anything you like
and the chances are your version of
Canon would be quite similar to someone
else's to me personally the notion of as
a thought that's quite a terrifying one
to think about not because I'm scared of
its appearance or its motives but
because the concept of our universe
being a dream that can end at any time
is quite thought-provoking it's quite
similar to why the matrix became so
popular there is no way for us to have a
100% discredit this theory so it leads
to wild conspiracies in a ton of
interesting discussion so feel free to
share any thoughts stories or
interpretations that you find
interesting with me in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained